bonjour imaginez imaginez un journaliste
équipé d'un tel matériel pour réaliser
son métier au quotidien
à l'heure des réseaux sociaux et de
l'information en continu
vraisemblablement cela ferait sourire
du moins pas longtemps parce qu'on
envisagerait très rapidement de
l'envoyer au musée pour inadaptation à
l'évolution de l'environnement
je ne suis pas journaliste mais je suis
aux portes du musée et je ne veux pas y
aller c'est trop tôt j'ai encore des
choses à apporter
je vais vous faire une confidence je
m'appelle effectivement gérard bayard
mais mon métier c'est vendeur
bien sûr quand on est vendeur on ne crie
pas sur les toits on fait ça incognito
parce que les mauvaises langues disent
que ça rime avec menteur et même avec
voleurs alors on trouve des termes
divers et variés pour camoufler cette
tare d'abord j'étais attaché commercial
je devrais dire ligoté commercial
tellement j'avais peu de latitude des
plantes tournée qui était parfaitement
calé et un discours qui était figée et
puis avec le temps j'ai pris du galon je
suis devenu ingénieur commercial c'est
beaucoup plus noble
si vous aviez vu les yeux de ma mère
lorsqu'elle a vu un ingénieur sur la
carte de visite
elle s'est dit comment mon fils fait
pour devenir ingénieur en faisant le
représentant de commerce
ça fait partie des miracles de la vente
qu'après je suis devenu chef des ventes
suffisant et j'ai même fini comme
président alors ça ça on n'ose avouer ce
président c'est toujours vendeur savez
un vendeur c'est quelqu'un qui est payé
pour convaincre ou plus exactement qui
les paient que s'il a convaincu est
président on n'arrête pas de convaincre
alors bien sûr il y aller les clients ce
ne sont pas les pires les collaborateurs
mais il ya également les banquiers et il
ya les pouvoirs publics
on vend en permanence je vais vous faire
un aveu je n'ai pas le moral parce que
je suis en instance de divorce alors pas
avec mon épouse avec mon épouse ça va
très bien c'est avec les clients que ça
ne va plus je crois qu'on va se séparer
alors j'ai vécu une histoire d'amour
absolument fabuleuse avec mes clients et
tout se passait bien jusqu'au moment où
en 2010 ça a été la désillusion
l'horreur absolue il y à un tabloïd qui
a osé publié en première page de
couverture incompétent et intrusif
les français nous disent les joueurs
c'est un tabloïd qui s'appelle le monde
qui a osé titrer sa incompétent et
intrusif
ça fait mal genou savez mal aimés mais
de là à être maudit ça fait beaucoup
pour un seul pourra seul individu
alors je n'ai pas compris je n'ai pas
compris parce que toute ma vie j'avais
fait des tas d'efforts pour sauver ma
relation avec les clients
essayer de sauver le couple alors bien
sûr j'avais acheté psychologies magazine
je m'étais intéressé à l' écoute active
pour répondre à leurs attentes il paraît
que c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire et
puis comme ce n'était pas suffisant
j'ai travaillé les clés de la séduction
pour s'intéresser à l'individu plutôt
que la fonction j'ai même traîné un peu
sur les chemins de la persuasion à la
limite de la manipulation je dois
l'avouer
et pour terminer j'ai travaillé les
démonstrations parce que faute de
déchaîner les passions
peut-être que par la raison j'allais
pouvoir bâtir une relation pérenne mais
ça n'a pas été suffisant ça n'a pas été
suffisant parce que comme toujours le
monde évolue et les nouvelles approches
proviennent de loin elle provenait la
des états unis où un magasin avait
inventé un nouveau modèle de vente en
injectant de l'émotion dans la
transaction sur le moment je n'ai pas
compris c'est lorsque j'ai vu le profil
des nouveaux vendeurs que je me suis dit
que manifestement il fallait envisager
autre chose
tout ça pour quoi
tout ça pour faire un triste constat
c'est que malgré tous ses efforts la
relation était laquelle on se voit de
moins en moins avec les clients obtenir
un rendez-vous c'est la croix et la
bannière
ils viennent de moins en moins dans les
magasins et quand ils viennent c'est
pourquoi c'est pour parler d'argent
constamment du début à la fin et de la
remise
et puis entre nous l'infidélité
parfaitement assumé on zappe en
permanence et c'est ça qu'on appelle une
relation durable
que s'était-il passé une frais
interrogations pour moi le monde avait
changé et ça en tant que vendeur la tête
dans le guidon je ne l'avais pas vue
venir
et là il faut prendre un petit peu de
hauteur pour voir en quoi l'univers a
été bouleversé pendant des siècles des
lits des millénaires
tout tournait autour de trois grands
fléaux les famine les épidémies et les
guerres on dirait que les épidémies on
en parle actuellement mais c'est ce qui
rythme est le monde et qui faisait des
dégâts terribles des dizaines de
millions de morts
et l'homme était focalisé sur sa survie
plus que sur autre chose en l'espace de
deux décennies
trois constats stupéfiants un
bouleversement profond
aujourd'hui il faut savoir qu'on meurt
plus de trop manger que pas assez
ce qui est absolument terrible
aujourd'hui c'est que en 2030 1 50 % de
l'humanité sera en surcharge pondérale
c'est absolument terrible de faire ce
constat on parle d'épidémie certes et
c'est l'épidémie la grippe espagnole a
fait plus de 20 millions de morts en
1918 plus de victimes que la première
guerre mondiale et même si on est en
pleine épidémie
aujourd'hui le risque de mourir de
vieillesse est bien supérieur au risque
de mourir d'épidémie vous me direz soit
mais alors ce qui se passe c'est que
malgré tout ça aujourd'hui on mange un
autre fin on vit beaucoup plus longtemps
et la probabilité d'accord d'être
déséquilibré de plus en plus faible et
pourtant l'homme est de plus en plus mal
le nombre de suicides
aujourd'hui et dans le monde supérieur
au nombre de victimes de crimes
d'attentats et de cayres et de guerre
réunis l'homme vit un profond malaise et
je prouve ce profond malaise fait que
les aspirations ne sont plus du tout les
mêmes
on est passé d'une quête de pib de
produits sains
arrières brut à une quête de bonheur
intérieur brut
cette mutation a fait que l'homme avait
changé en l'espace d'une décennie
le bouleversement a fait que l'homme est
devenu un animal connecter à l'ère de la
connaissance
on s'est rendu compte que la profusion
d'informations il est tellement simple
d'accéder à l'information
mais l'accès à l'information à donner
l'illusion de la connaissance et du
pouvoir mais tout ça n'est qu'une
illusion
ça a créé un nouveau type d'individu que
j'appelle les autonomistes
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
autonomistes un autonomiste est
quelqu'un qui considère qu'il n'a besoin
de personne pour prendre sa décision
il sait ce qu'il veut et les capable de
l'imposer
même si ce n'est qu'illusion du pouvoir
je vais vous montrer ce que c'est que le
canal historique des autonomistes le
canal historique n'est pas le plus
dangereux le canal historique
quand il va chez le médecin il est très
à l'aise il va voir le médecin en lui
disant docteur je suis venu vous voir
parce que j'ai une douleur dans le bas
du dos jean situe l'origine entre elles
5 et ça je vous ai amené un support pour
bourgeois y est bien
il s'agit d'un passement vertébrale à un
glissement d'un disque lombaire le long
du tissu rachidien qui se traduit par
une douleur portet qui part du haut de
la fesse qui descend le nom de la jambe
et qui est particulièrement douloureuse
ce sont les symptômes d'une sciatique
vous avez raison vous voyez il ya des
autonomistes dans la salle ils sont
partout alors docteur si vous voulez
bien notés pour une sciatique vous allez
me donner des anti inflammatoires
je prendrai du voltarène ou du felden
peu importe la marque du moment que ce
soit du diclofénac un décontracturants
sera d affaires en help et parce que je
n'ai pas envie de multiplier les prises
journalières
comme tout ça c'est pas bon pour
l'estomac vous mettrez un gars pansement
gastrique ce que vous voulez ça n'a pas
d'importance
puis docteur docteur notez bien vous
mettrez huit jours à ce que les faux
jumeaux revêtent imaginer imaginez la
situation du médecin confronté à ce type
d'individu
il a deux possibilités soit ils
acceptent ils acceptent mais dans ce cas
là on le traiterait de faire du
clientélisme
c'est une insulte faire du clientélisme
pour un médecin ou un homme politique
c'est répondre aux attentes exprimées
par autrui sans faire la part des choses
et dire que moins vendeur j'ai été payé
toute ma vie pour faire du clientélisme
alors le canal historique
il est pacifique globalement il vit avec
ses illusions et surtout il est
contrôlable
parce que le vernis de connaissances est
extrêmement superficielle et le médecin
qui ne veut pas faire de clientélisme
va savoir reprendre la main assez
rapidement il va s'y prendre comment il
va dire vous allez commencer par vous
déshabiller oui complètement
c'est assez efficace s'il ya des
vendeurs dans la salle je déconseille de
mettre en pratique en clientèle ça
présente des risques et une fois que le
client est déshabillé il est allongé sur
une table
il s'agit d'appuyer exactement à
l'endroit où ça fait mal et l'autre y
aie aie aie aie
vous l'imaginez et là je vais avoir
besoin de votre aide
parce que pour reprendre la main il va
falloir prendre un ascendant émotionnel
le médecin ne dit plus rien et
commencent à s'interroger et là il faut
apprendre à faire le pas je voudrais
vous entendre un dia et le médecin de
dire dites moi si je me trompe mais il
me semble que vous connaissez bien votre
pathologie
ça veut dire que à plusieurs reprises
vous avez pris ce traitement n'est ce
pas brive est tout à fait et ça n'a pas
donné les résultats escomptés puisque
vous êtes revenu me voir c'est bien ça à
a tardé dites-moi est-ce que de temps en
temps vous ne sentez pas un
fourmillement tellement fort que il y à
une perte de sensibilité dans la jambe
droite d'autres qui dit oui alors là on
fait à aa
voilà là on a remis la quiétude alors si
je vous dis tout ça c'est pas pour vous
embêter jeu pourrait prescrire ce que
vous voulez dites moi où
on prend les choses à la va vite où on
le fait sérieusement si je vous dis tout
ça c'est pour vous en quelques minutes
le médecin avait repris l'ascendant un
ascendant émotionnel un ascendant
professionnel et un ascendant
relationnel c'est pour votre bien que je
fais ça malheureusement le canal
historique n'était pas le seul
derrière il y avait le canal hystérique
alors ça c'est autre chose contrairement
au premier le canal hystérique et
polémiques
il est atteint du syndrome tripadvisor
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est à dire
que sous couvert d'anonymat
sous couvert d'anonymat il est capable
de déverser des torrents de haine et le
canal polémique et est capable de
détruire une image en quelques minutes
l'image d'un produit d'un restaurant
d'une société d'un homme voire même d'un
régime
le problème du canal historique c'est
qu'il est polémique est absolument
ingérable
parce que il a entre les mains une arme
de destruction massive épouvantable les
réseaux sociaux hystérique au sens
littéral du terme
c'est une expression exagérée des
émotions que ce soit dans l'engouement
ou dans le dénigrement et quand on fait
ça sous couvert de la nomine de
l'anonymat ça devient absolument
catastrophique
alors ils ont une maîtrise de cette arme
de destruction massive
ils ont complètement compris ce qu'était
la viralité la viralité c'était l'art et
la manière d'être vu par le plus grand
nombre de personnes le plus longtemps
possible et pour ça il fallait être très
sec qu'il fallait être cru très crue
dans la communication et plus on était
cru et agressif plus en été vues et plus
ont été vues plus on été cru
donc on peut raconter n'importe quoi du
moment qu'on soit vu par beaucoup de
monde ça fonctionne
l'horreur des nouveaux acteurs sont
arrivés ça ça m'a fait très mal
des nouveaux acteurs des nouveaux
vendeurs a bien entendu une s'appelle
pas vendeur il s'appelle blogueurs
il s'appelle influenceurs pour marquerez
que ça rime toujours avec vendeur et
puis vous voyez fois si vous le pensez
alors ça m'a fait très mal parce que
pendant que je travaillais
tranquillement à la maison et qu'il
faisait des millions de j'aime moi
j'essayais de me battre pour rencontrer
des clients qui ne venaient pas me
recevoir
je faisais des millions de vues pendant
que moi je faisais des milliers de
kilomètres heure the de kilomètres mais
malheureusement les indemnités
kilométriques ça ne suffit pas pour
nourrir son âme
alors je me suis dit suis jeune ancien
modèle a recyclé
est-ce que c'est fini un vendeur d'hier
cette prise de conscience a été a été
terrible et pourtant ce que j'avais
constaté c'est que la connivence et est
devenue plus importante que la
compétence donc il fallait que je
repense à ma manière de travailler et
c'est en 2015 que j'ai eu une révélation
alors cette révélation elle a été
violente
elle a été très violente c'est qu'en
2015 je suis devenue la moitié de moi
même et quand je dis la moitié de moi
même qui au sens littéral du terme
j'ai fait un accident vasculaire
cérébrale sévère qui m'a rendu
complètement émis hémiplégique paralysé
du côté gauche et je me suis retrouvé
dans un fauteuil roulant à devoir tout
réapprendre à marcher mais après à
manger et un habillés mais surtout
j'étais devenu est miné glee j'en ai mis
négligence c'est que le côté gauche
n'existait plus cela signifie que je
voyais à gauche mais le cerveau ne
traitait plus l'information de ce qu'il
ya à gauche un emmy d'exigence sévère ne
sera ce que la moitié du visage puisque
l'autre moitié n'existe pas il ne mange
que la moitié de son assiette
parce que l'autre moitié n'existe pas un
ennemi négligent demande à ce qu'on lui
arrache un membre intrus passe quand il
le rencontre dans son lit la nuit
c'est angoissant pour lui alors vous me
direz quel rapport avec ce qu'on a fait
est bien c'est que pour la première fois
de ma vie
j'allais disposer de temps de temps et
d'une volonté farouche d'apprendre et de
comprendre
de comprendre comment fonctionne et mon
cerveau et quelle était la probabilité
qu'un jour je récupère et je recommence
à vivre normalement
ce fut une révélation extraordinaire
extraordinaire parce que j'ai compris ce
jour là que le cerveau n'en fait qu'à sa
tête
il en fait qu'à sa tête dans la manière
coop d'absorber de l'information le
cerveau est boulimique on gobe à peu
près toute forme d'information par tous
les sens par la vue par louis parle par
le toucher on consomme sans limite à
s'en faire exploser la tête
boulimique n'est un show baez qu'est ce
que ça veut dire que le problème n'est
pas l'ingestion
le problème c'est la digestion surtout
quand vous mettez de l'information a
varié mélangé au reste ça fait un drôle
de bazar et la quantité d'informations a
varié et que l'on consomme chaque jour
est phénoménal
j'ai constaté également que j'avais
commis toute ma vie une erreur
fondamentale moi qui cherchait à
convaincre mes interlocuteurs j'avais
commis l'erreur de descartes l'erreur de
descartes c'est de considérer que
l'individu étonné est un animal
raisonnable un animal raisonnable qui
est capable de faire passer la raison
avant la passion regardez cette image
difficile d'imaginer ce dilemme entre la
passion et la raison ce chien ne va pas
hésité longtemps nous nous sommes santé
censée et hésiter et au final faire en
sorte que la raison soit plus forte que
l'émotion mais ça c'est de la
littérature parce que la réalité n'est
pas là dans la décision d'achat en
particulier nos décisions d'achat ne
sont pas du tout raisonnable
on passe notre temps à acheter des
produits dont on n'a pas besoin avec de
l'argent qu'on n'a même pas pour épater
des gens qu'on ne connaît même pas la
réalité elle est là n'est ce pas alors
si pendant des années
j'avais déployé une énergie phénoménale
à convaincre des clients ou des
interlocuteurs par la raison j'avais
découvert que ce qui était fondamental
c'est l impact de l'émotion
l'heure de la transformation est arrivé
il fallait réinventer le métier pour
être aujourd'hui compétents et avoir une
chance de vivre dans cet environnement
j'ai passé deux ans dans un centre de
rééducation fonctionnelle pour tout
réapprendre
quand le disque dur est effacé il y a
trois étapes à suivre et ses trois
étapes sur les étapes de la
transformation
la première c'est une étape de
récupération cette récupération c'est
faire en sorte que tout redevienne comme
avant tout seul sans faire d'efforts et
c'est vrai que j'ai récupéré
j'ai récupéré pendant quelques semaines
et après c'est trop tard
comme il ya des tas de vendeurs qui
espère que tout redeviendra comme avant
malheureusement ce n'est plus le cas les
clients ayant changé alors là on est
obligé de passer à la phase 2 la
patience n'est pas suffisante il va
falloir passer en phase de rééducation
et la phase de rééducation
c'est recommencer et recommencer les
mêmes mouvements pour avoir une chance
de re se retrouver comme avant grâce à
la rééducation j'ai appris à marcher
et pour ça c'est de la persévérance
recommencer cent fois le même le même
mouvement
et pourquoi on le re commence tant qu'on
a de la motivation on est capable de
travailler et ce qui fait la motivation
c'est la réussite
le jour où il n'y a plus de réussite de
réussite il n'y a plus de motivation
combien de vendeurs se sont démotivés
parce que malgré leurs efforts ils ne
générait plus les résultats attendus
alors il faut passer en stade 3 et le
stade iii c'est la réadaptation la
réadaptation c'est admettre que plus
jamais ce sera comme avant car son que
j'ai rencontrés au centre de rééducation
fonctionnelle qui avait perdu une jambe
voir les deux dans un accident la
probabilité de les voir marcher comme
avant et est nul
et pourtant ils allaient continuer à
vivre et remarquablement bien
mais pour cela il faut faire preuve de
résilience c'est à dire d'acceptation
d'acceptation de repenser totalement son
mode de vie pour aborder les choses
différemment si au lieu de se dit
que ça c'était avant
on se posait la question et si demain
était plus beau et s'il existait un
avenir meilleur que celui que l'on a que
l'on a vécu à l'image de cette céramique
japonaise qui selon la philosophie du
kin sougy où on ne masque pas les
fêlures on les répare alors dans le kin
sougy la case d'une céramique ne
signifie pas sa fin mais le début d'une
nouvelle étape plus belle que la prési
la précédente
alors je m'adresse à tous les faits les
atouts les cabossés qui peuvent
considérer que après un problème il
existe un renouveau et je leur souhaite
à tous que 2020 soit l'année du
renouveau je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]